à t'entendre attends tu te rends compte
du travail train de faire là
oui voilà salle d eau la saleté all away
une histoire d'amour c'est une grande
histoire une grande aventure
ces deux êtres très différents qui
sommes pas compliqué merde moi je veux
manger je mange
voulez vous excuser alesi bordel on
attend le moment où ils vont se rendre
compte qu'ils sont faits l'un pour
l'autre et je l'aï berthier mise à nu
nouvelle lancinant chapelle bonjour il
savait s'est quelque peu coincé alors au
début en tout cas je crois qu'elle est
un peu train train puisque c'était qu'un
trait quotidien quelqu'un qui pense
avoir trouvé le bonheur dans sa vie
épuisement et qui est cette
particularité que premier amoureux n'est
jamais le bon mes grands-mères mettant
mes cousines toutes les femmes du se
remarier pour être heureuse
c'est notre malédiction donc elle est
prête à tout pour essayer de se marier
pour divorcer pour retrouver son jeu des
merlus qui rentrent après le marié
divorcé je ne trouve pas les piqûres
donc elles payent pour des faits de
mariage bidon au danemark puis comme ça
marche pas elle choisit une autre
solution qui est la plus mauvaise foi
des solutions je suis trouvée par
quelques habitants
j'ai vu qu'elle fait semblant d'être
folle de lui et amoureuse pour le vide
se marier et vite divorcée elle le fou
par terre tu m'a chanté accepté pivot
13h37 avoir du mal à s'en remettre
j'arrive venez voir
la manipulation est un point de départ
qui permet d'amener des situations
comité fort tout en fait les désirs des
personnages contradictoires donc c'est
plus une histoire de séduction au final
pas titulaire
mais dernière
et puis ce match de la même tu m'as bout
cholet merde
puis ce matin mais c'est quoi pour vous